hello YouTube just lovers no offense
this is guns in here today I have
brought something new for you
many people frustrate again d4 because
they hardly find any attacking or
tactical line and that's where the
attacking gambits comes into the picture
this gambits not only try by beginners
to advanced labor player but it has been
also oftenly try by masters and the GMS
where the win matters most so let's go
through some of the nice gambit idea
against default now here I have 5
gambits for you and I will go through
these gambits as per their popularity at
the higher level there is one thing I
like to mention before we start that
instead of showing you the line what I
have done in this video is I'm going to
show you some of the noise resources
which I have personally gone through it
and I found it very very dynamic as well
as interesting so in this video I'm
going to show you the glimpse of the
gambits and then I'm going to show you
the major resources of it so let's get
started
number five we have the alb encounter
gambit which occurs when black responds
with the move defy and after c4 which is
a Queen's Gambit black responds with the
move e5 to illustrate how dangerous this
gambit is let me show you one of the
nice trap which is known as the Alban
trap which occurs when white capture the
epode and after black responds with the
move d4 the very initial response of the
white is to get rid of this pawn why are
the move III and here the Bishop b4
check occurs and when white normally
black the check with the bishop let's
say Bishop to d2 then black has a
fantastic shot which is d cross C 3 and
after Bishop captures Bishop and pawn
captures f2 you can see the king cannot
capture this pawn because the Queen is
hanging so King has to come up
afterwards
black will capture the knight and create
a knight which has a check to the king
and if white capture this night then
black has this cure which is Bishop to
g4 and white queen is a goner so this is
one wonderful trap exist in Albion and
there are many more like this and that's
why this line is very very interesting
there are two good resources for the alb
encounter gambit the first one is the
Andrew Martin has created one foxy
opening video and which I personally
follow some of his lines and I have an
excellent result and the second one is
the GM Rustom chasm journal has done a
very amazing video and I'll be encounter
gambit for the experts
at number four we have the bloomin full
gambit which occurs when black responds
with the move Knight to f6 and the most
frequent reply of the white is to move
Knight to f3 and this is one gambit
which is very very good against Knight
to f3 so you better watch out this
gambit here black more to start with the
nimzo-indian defense so it start with
the movie 6 and after the normal-looking
move the c4 here comes the idea which is
the move c5 if white wants to retain any
advantage then white has to come forward
and here comes the blumenfield gambits
start with the move b5 to give you an
illustration how dangerous this is
let me show you one of the main lines so
white capture first of all this pawn and
after black recaptures with the F pawn
now white except is gambit with C cross
B file and now black will take the
center with the move d5 and idea is very
simple if white allow black will always
recapture that pawn so white has to stop
it with the move III and now the good
thing which I like about this gambit
idea is the black piece layout are
pretty much fixed and they are very very
aggressively placed so let's see how the
black develop is species so first of all
black will play Bishop to d6 and let's
say white plays Knight to c3
now black will play Bishop to d7 and
after Bishop to e2 castle from both the
side black will play Knight to d7 and
after b3 black will play Queen to e7 and
after Bishop to b2 the rope can come to
either C file or the D file let's say in
this game black plays rook to d8 and
after Queen to c2
now comes the movie five and we should
stop over here and look at what we get
from a pond you can see this - bishop
this raking - bishops are looking
towards the king side of the white not
only that the important factor is these
three points are covering the whole
fourth rank that means white PCs are
very much cramped and the big asset from
the black perspective is black has the
open F file and in some cases the nasty
sacrifices are looming
there are two good resources in the
blumenfield gambit the first one is the
FM boris Alterman has done a gambit
guide video for the blue moon flick
gambit where he demonstrate this gambit
in a very nice way so if you starting
out this blumenfield gambit this
resource I'm certainly going to
recommend the second good resource in
this line is the Andrew Martin again has
done a foxy opening video and that's
where he has shown some excellent
attacking line which you might want to
try out
at number three we have the Vaughn
handing shower gambit which are caused
when black responds with the move defy
and after the move c4 we have the Queens
gambit declined variation start with the
move e six the normal-looking white move
over here is Knight to c3 afterwards
black has this move which is the C file
also known as a tirage defense and the
Tara's the main line goes like this so
why capture the D pawn in order to give
an isolated pawn but now comes one
hanging shower gambit shot which is the
move C cross default so it's attacking
the knight so that means white response
is pretty much forced and now black of
the response with the move Knight to c6
attacking the Queen
so Queen has to drop backs and now black
is going to capture that one in a way
black is gamma ting upon and white will
certainly capture this pawn with the
Queen hoping that black will exchange
the Queen but now comes the beautiful
move which is Bishop to d7 and you will
think what on earth
black will get out of this to illustrate
attacking power of this gambit
let me show you one of my own game so
here my opponent responded with the move
Bishop to g5 attacking my queen so I
played Knight to f6 counter attacking
his Queen so he dropped his queen back
to the d2 and now I played the move at
six attacking the bishop so he capture
my night and I recapture with the Queen
if I play the move III so developing his
other Bishop but now comes the whole
idea so black castle on the Queen side
and you can immediately see this rook
has been put against the Queen so white
has to be careful and in this game my
opponent completely neglect the
potential of it
he played the Moon Knight to f3 which
give him the image a disaster so I
played the move Bishop to g4 attacking
the knight not only that it's also
attacking the Queen and that means my
response is pretty much forced White has
to play Queen to e2
afterwards black plays the move Bishop
to b5 and you can see why it is already
past it now
there are two good resources for the
worn Hanning shara gambit
the first one is boys al Sherman has
done a gambit guide on the one handing
shower gambit where he has shown some of
the nice master games and also given the
nice concept of this gambit so if you
starting out this is the ideal video for
you and the second good resources is the
foxy opening volume 90 which is again
done by the end room 18 where he has
shown some excellent work and you can
also use this line as a secret weapon in
the tournament
at number 2 we have the budapest gambit
which is one of my old favorite secret
weapon it occurs when black is pawns
with the move Knight to f6
and when white responds with the move c4
here comes the idea which is the move e5
more or less if white wants to retain
any advantage then he has to take the
spawn and afterwards black has a 2
response which is 94 and 94 I personally
like Knight to g4 because that's the
main line and that is I'm going to
recommend to you so Knight to g4
attacking the pawn to demonstrate its
power let me show you one of my own game
which was very attacking and a tactical
game so here my opponent responded with
the move Knight to f3 I responded with
Bishop to c5 attacking the f2 so more or
less White has to play the move III and
now I played the move Knight to c6
attacking the pawn one more time and
here my opponent decided to give up this
pawn and carried out his normal piece
development so he played Bishop to e2 I
Castle on the Kings side so did he and
now I get my pawn back and here he
played Knight to c3 here I played the
very cunning war which first of all I
capture this night and after white we
capture I played Knight to e5 so if I'm
allowed I'll gain the bishop pet and my
position will become free so he played
Bishop to e2 and now I played the move
eh here the very obvious response is the
move a 3 so trying to get the B for you
so we should stop that with the movie
file but Aoife has another deadly idea
that you are about to see so in this
game my opponent responded with the
movie 3 but now comes the shocking move
which is rook to a six and my idea is
very simple I want to put my rukon at
six it will combine with the move Queen
to h4 and then I'm going to mate wide on
the edge tool let's see how this game
progress so my opponent responded with
the move Bishop to g2 I played the
immediate Queen to h4 and here white
think that I missed something so he
played the move Knight to defy trying to
folk the to rook but now I played the
MOOC - at six so more or less white has
to play the move s3 and now I
cold-bloodedly play the move d6 and my
opponent greedily captured the c7
afterwards can guess yep is Bishop to h3
BAM
now in budahas gambit there are three
good resources the first one is again
the Buddha's Alterman gambit guide where
he has nicely present the basic idea of
the wood of his gambit but the second
one which I like the most which is the
Andrew Martin has done a Fritz trainer
DVD on this and I have prepared my to
nominal
personally for me this is one of the
best video on the fritz trainer by the
intro Martin the third one is the GM
James Baskett has done a foxy opening
video on this where he done a good
overview of this budapest defense
number one we have the bank or gambit
after d4 black responds with the Moon
Knight to f6 and after c4 black responds
with the move c5 and again if white
wants to get any advantage then white
has to push forward
so the defy is very natural but now
comes the Banco gambit idea with the MU
B 5 what is the idea behind the B file
to illustrate it or let me show you the
complete acceptance of this gambit white
capture this pawn and when I play the a3
he captured that phone again and here
but obvious response is Bishop to e3 so
I'm stopping white castle on the King
side and here my opponents pointed with
the move Knight to c3
I played the move d6 and now he
responded with the movie 4 here I
captured the bishop and after a white
recapture
I played the move g3 and after Knight to
f3 Knight B to d7 and g3 I played Bishop
to g7 my opponent responded with King to
g2
and after I Castle on the Kings side he
plays rook to even so you know where
White has done the artificial castle and
is asking black what you get for the one
pawn well here comes Dan so so first of
all black will play Queen to b6 and
after Queen to c2 rook
2bh and the whole concept of this
opening is to play on this a and B V
pawns believe it or not but just for the
one ball black has a tremendous
attacking potential and that's why it's
a more preferable choice at the higher
level there are two excellent resources
for the bank or gambit the first one is
the end room Martin has done an
excessive amount of work on this bank or
gambit lines and he has created too foxy
opening videos which is about acceptance
as well as decline and he has also done
a Fritz trainer video where he combined
Lee shown a unique idea of the Banco
gambit but the best resources I found
out on the Internet is the GM L Sandra
Ramirez which he has recently launches
the Banco gambit series and he has given
in part 1 and part 2 where in part 1 he
has covered the acceptance line and in
second part he has covered what you
should do when you opponent deviate from
the Banco gambit
so there you have it now you can
confidently meet default with this nice
attacking gambits and look forward for
your winning chances now I haven't
included any book references over here
because I hardly use books in the chats
but if you have any good resources then
please write down in the comments thank
you for watching my video and I'll meet
you soon bye